The specific lesson objectives for this lesson are,
we will look at the photographic process for both digital and film cameras.
I will describe to you, the eight different layers that constitute a color film.
I will also describe the five layers of a generic CCD that's found in
most common cameras.
We will discuss the differences between a charged couple device, a CCD and
a CMOS sensor.
And I will discuss some of the benefits of using a camera raw format.
This will connect back to the lecture we had on different types of
image formats.
Remember, it's the image format that basically captures the pixels.
And it's the pixel values,
the intensities, which we want to be doing most of our processing on.
We will just take that up a notch and
talk about a camera raw format a bit today.